we're here in game three with the white
pieces to take the win and the match and
here we go
oh we've been talking about nhs he
really needs to wave his magic wand now
duder
yeah he needs to get back into this
match yeah so far he's just been
outgunned he's been outclassed by liam
and uh with black it won't be easy
okay queen's gambit declined so far what
will liam choose how will he kind of
take the sting out of this game
okay he brings this knight out they call
this the main position where black has a
bunch of choices i was going to say duda
often plays this the vienna variation
grabbing a pawn temporarily as black
it's very ambitious
yeah this guy's thinking a couple of
four straws aren't there in this in this
variation that uh duder has to avoid the
black pieces that's sometimes the
problem playing uh you know the black
pieces if if white wants to he can he
you know he's aware of the theory he can
go to
a drawing line this is the move i play
actually i don't have to and i give up
the pawn but it's a little bit dangerous
maybe in the match situation yeah i mean
the thing is though liam is a very
highly combative player and
we just see it's not very easy for him
to switch styles so he where he will he
will play in the most uncompromising way
now black does have a choice he can
actually develop the dark squared bishop
and pin the knight or he can also okay
that's what we see he can also defend
the pawn by picking up the b pawn and
moving it two squares
and now we are in the variation called
the vienna
i love i love this position as white
it's one of my favorite opening
variations there you know you can give
up the pawn and get a tremendous
initiative with just bishop takes born
here and he's played that which i think
is quite a scary line for black in
general theoretically
but dude has got to take some risks so
at least he's a porn up if he can
survive um the attack which you'll
probably face soon and uh incidentally
this particular variation was actually
recommended by sam shanklin in his
chassis wall course
and uh
from the white the white side from the
white side yeah because you can there
are other moves available to white you
don't have to sacrifice a pawn but sam
you know he has a very committal style
he says okay
here you should
i think i think it's very principled
right to sacrifice the pawn because
um black's got very bad development
white's got lovely development and look
at black's king's side black has to put
the king over there this is this is one
of the sharper variations which can lead
to for a forced draw if i remember
correctly so this is the problem with
the way black's playing i can't remember
the fourth draw but i'm sure there's
some
four straw here somewhere yeah
in these lines i've looked at them from
the black side a few times
i i was just too scared to ever touch
them because even if black knows
everything then as you mentioned simon
you might be able to get the draw and i
mean white is just two or three moves
ahead with development often if you're
two moves ahead with
development that does
uh equal a pawn and uh maybe if we just
check in to show why black didn't grab a
second pawn in this position uh white
has already given up at the central pawn
if he grabs here
i mean there's plenty of ways as far as
i know you can even bring your bishop
out just to cut the king off to stop the
black king from castling
it will never castle to safety now and
even if black goes and grabs an exchange
in the corner then uh this is just a
disaster for black black's king i mean
look at all of plaque's pieces they are
just all asleep
especially on this side of the board and
if you can't castle either due to this
x-ray vision of the bishop it's just
game over white is actually going to
push forward open up a diagonal and his
queen will hit this pawn this is just
unacceptable so he retreated he didn't
kind of allow the white bishop to enter
this diagonal and now the white knight
jumping forward
okay this last move by black
i
oh again i remember studying this
position and this wasn't the move kind
of asking for it yeah he's asking for so
many sacrifices here i think i'm
supposed to kick away this knight if i
remember correctly uh but
yeah you've mentioned sacrifice to simon
i mean that is top computer choice you
know he's a couple right i mean he's got
knight f7 bishop e6 die east i mean the
queen can also come out threatened good
old-fashioned scholars mate
that's a great move
but the top
computer suggestion
uh is actually bishop takes pawn wow
okay so i mean even these natural moves
look strong but bishop takes pawn ivanka
wow giving up a piece
if black captures if like takes the bait
then i guess we just recapture with the
knight hitting the queen wherever the
queen runs
do we just play it slow just move the
rook that's right you gotta play in a
classy way and uh the rook lines up
against the king and if the king tries
to get out of dodge town then
unfortunately it's not gonna get that
far because after a check the king is
forced to step back
okay i can understand why this wasn't
played
because this move that was played looks
really good as well without giving up a
piece right because you're forcing
black's response and now the queen can
still stop black from castling and
you've got all these frets
against black's king
looks horrendous for blackness position
i mean you're stuck in the center you're
suffering just for the just for the
price of one pawn
and yeah as you mentioned simon all of
these variations even that last one we
showed with the knight black and never
ever castle and if you can't castle what
are you doing do you really have to step
back undevelop your piece with the
bishop to kick away the white queen
white's queen will just slide back and
again these types of ideas are all on
the cards
i mean everything's just pointing at the
black king that looks really scary i
mean i'm all in favor of retreating this
dark square bishop and just
[Laughter]
praying but here off i mean white's
attacking with one piece two pieces
three pieces soon it will be a fourth
soon this bishop will join in it will be
a fifth piece
how many defenders are there i mean
it's not enough simply yeah this is
terrible it's looking good for liam lee
remember he only needs a draw in this
game to win the match and take all three
points against the young christophe duda
and liam he did stop by sweden for a
comment after the previous game that he
won let's hear what liam said
in a second
we were
saying before the match today that you
were looking to reset after game one you
thought you got lucky but maybe that was
the start of some great chess to come
yeah probably i think this round game
two is perhaps my best game so far in
the tournament it was a really
complicated game and
i think i outplayed him in the middle
game i cannot say if i was
better on the way but i think i managed
to find some really good move
dude is a player that you
seem to play well against why is that
well he's a very fighting player so
we are always getting interesting
positions and
i like playing him
you like playing the championship here
as well especially when it's going like
this right yeah definitely we look
forward to seeing more good chess from
julia thank you
that is very understandable liam
enjoying himself probably also in this
position but expecting some fighting
chess from duda is that what young
christoph duda
is doing in this game david just trying
to
bring a fight yeah i mean he's inviting
the whole white army into his camp he's
just saying okay my king's in the center
it's a target
but
i mean i don't think he's
used his magic wand enough here duda
because all the magic he's trying to
make work it's just it's all in white's
favor i mean oh look look at the bar
yeah you know it's well up in uh you
know liam with his favor
well spotted simon
shows how much he's dominating the
position finally the grand masters as
well is recognizing the bar i'm so happy
the bar is a powerful thing exactly yeah
not like you two hang out in bars and
look at bars
do you like my bars occasionally
but it's a dude's last move at least it
kind of holds some squares together
black is only two moves away from
actually achieving a decent position um
let's jump in and show what has happened
uh we i mean we're definitely a favor of
white here i think all of us but uh in
order to make the breakthrough we need
to be quite quick
uh black if we if given time for example
if white just waits too slowly makes a
nothing move if black can move his
bishop and suddenly castle the king to
safety black is a pawn up and suddenly
this white queen will look a bit silly
having entered the wrong side of the
board on the wrong side of black's army
so we need to do something in this
current position if we backtrack we need
to do something now before black and
moves bishop and castle the king so we
have two moves
we need
something at least we need some kind of
um some kind of creativity some kind of
magic
what do you what do we think here i'm
struggling to see a big breakthrough be
nice if you can move pieces on the same
squares as other pieces
you want to use this square for the
bishop yeah so i kind of want to get rid
of that knight i mean i i think taking
the pawn is just not
it might be okay but it's not nothing
special probably
i mean even rook b1 is probably okay but
um just improving uh but
maybe move the knight back somewhere but
i don't like moving pieces backwards if
i can
i moving the
um the knight back does kind of create
this threat maybe
with a really nasty pin i say kind of
because black could
possibly allow it and then jump out the
way with his knight uh with a counter
attack like allowing this queen to drop
uh hitting the white queen but here
white has various ways to maybe win
material so yeah the problem is maybe
for liam's too many tempting moves kind
of do you drop back initiate this threat
of a pin
uh do you i mean i really like this move
simon this piece is the only one doing
nothing and you just slide across making
it
kind of
unattractive for black to move his
bishop because then this pawn would drop
and that's kind of a nice calm move
where you just throw the
okay i was gonna say you throw the move
back to black and you say what are you
actually doing but no he goes for the
direct threat
and this one is menaced now um the other
reason i wasn't 100 sure about this is
because black's rook can maybe kick the
queen out of uh
and kick the queen out it has to retreat
but this is still a nasty uh nasty idea
bishop to g5
yeah i mean somehow black it just
doesn't feel like he's going to be in
time to defend everything he'll have to
give up something maybe whether it's a
pawn
uh whether it's
castling rights
what do we think here i didn't really
see a move for black to be honest i mean
this type of pin is just deadly
if black castles now the white queen
steps back and
white breaks through on this diagonal
yeah i like this retreat i also like the
retreat it was also on my radar as well
um i'm stuck for a move from for black i
can't think of a single thing other than
maybe just develop the bishop and just
kind of
grit the teeth and go whoa that's ugly
but maybe it survives because after the
bishop comes out you do have the move
that you suggested the knight comes out
and counter attacks
but there you are giving
i guess white i mean firstly white could
take the queen and then take the rook
and white is an exchange up so rook for
bishop and porn so i don't think there's
much risk here for liam if he only needs
a draw this should be fine but also
after this knight jump maybe what
instead of taking the queen white can
just capture a pawn that looks really
scary yeah i mean you're gonna be safe
pawn up probably here still threatening
the queen if black blocks now you can
capture this pawn with a check
i mean this looks like uh disaster for
black the ver like you said simon very
minimum white will be a pawn up
all right well it could be a short day
for these two players young christopher
he has to win this game to take it to a
fourth game and potentially uh
armageddon it's looking uh or tiebreaks
it's looking good for liam if they do
have a short day well of course they can
hit the beach
in miami sweater is out and about the
arena what's going on sweater
well i found myself uh well my favorite
guest here alejandro ramirez it's it's
good to have someone to turn to in the
time of need and in the time of uh
wonder because right now we're seeing uh
liam leia who's suddenly playing good
chess again
yeah and i think that the fact that dude
is in so much trouble is not so much a
reflection of the polish player's
preparation but it's a reflection of
what happened in the first game le quang
he didn't play a very good opening and
duda was all over him but what happened
it was that lev was resilient and the
tables turned very suddenly on the
polish player and le quang ended up
winning that game with white wins the
second one in a row and now he seems up
2-0 normally in the tournament that's
classical you have a full day to recover
you can psychologically put yourself in
a new state but what happens in this
rapid matches boom the next game starts
and immediately duda goes wrong he
doesn't even need to go down to lose the
match legend is in full control of this
match and it's more of a reflection as i
said of what happened psychologically on
the first game of the day than on duda's
preparation or his playing ability i
thought it was interesting when liam
spoke to me quickly before walking into
the game that he really likes playing
against those guys who offer fighting
chess and duda is one of them why is
liam less so comfortable against
fighting chess players you think the
polish fighter is known to always bring
complications to to the board and what
le quang likes to do is have this
positionally sound situations over the
board and wait for his opponent to do
something too aggressive something that
invites complications but are perhaps
not sound and la quang is a brilliant
calculator and has the style to punish
this type of chess so i think that uh
liam lee has probably set the trap and
is ready to pounce
absolutely
thanks for that uh reports vada and
alejandro out and about in miami under
the burning sun
and liam
he can soon hit the beach if he uh just
gets a draw in this game what is the
most likely result right now in this
game um should we have a vote yeah i
think white win
i'd have to say a white win as well um
i think um doodle would rather lose and
draw anyway yeah
yeah it's going to be full house here we
don't really have any confidence
into this ability to turn this one
around and win it i i mean i think his
position is just too dangerous and i
think
liam will just win this yeah and the
thing is the evaluation bar says 0.8 uh
it doesn't
sound like much but that is even if
black defends super accurately like a
computer with all the best moves and
i think here in the studio we're
struggling to find any acceptable
defense dude are now thinking for five
minutes clearly he's struggling to find
an acceptable defense as well so
um even if he miraculous miraculously
stumbles across some defensive resource
then he still has an uh kind of a
disadvantage to face and in a must-win
situation that's not easy so 0.8 is that
almost three points
it's almost one point one point is zero
point nine is that it uh
plus one is one point four
okay so white's actually pouring down in
the position but the computer gives 0.8
advantage which is nearly one point
advantage so
that's how strong white's kind of
initiative the
momentum is that even being upon down
the computer gives him an advantage
i remember 10 years ago if you were pawn
down the computer not giving you any
advantage that just meant uh it's not
sound
computers were really distrustful they
were very materialistic but here
computers understand that white is doing
well and why can even there we go one
move
in a difficult position we can't fault
duda there it was very difficult from a
human point of view facing a scary
attack
but one bad move and it shoots up so
there's different types of 0.8
advantages different types of 0.5
some are very likely to grow
if the opponent doesn't find the best
defense and there we go liam has
recovered his pawn still with a massive
threat of bringing the dart squad bishop
in to attack the black queen
i was going to ask a very you kind of
you you put a question into my head
and that was because you asked about
this pawn
evaluation 0.1 0.8 one point whatever is
it easier if we were to go like 60
chance of winning
i know so norwegian tv too right when
they cover chess they use the percentage
you know 60 chance of winning
yeah yeah that's that's how a i uh like
alpha zero that's how they calculate
they
um when alpha zero evaluates a position
uh it would say to itself okay if i play
this position a hundred times against
myself how many times would i win ah and
it would say okay 52 or 68 or um and
that's how it evaluates rather than kind
of
general terms we say our white has a
slight advantage which could mean a
variety of things it could mean it's a
temporary advantage can mean a long-term
advantage
um or sometimes we say it's equal or
unclear but it could be equal but both
sides have chances to win or it could be
equal dead draw there's lots of
different uh ways so maybe the
percentage way
is the future
i do like the the kind of materialistic
way that the bar is showing us though
because i can sort of imagine one pawn
up or even like
oh a knight up that's uh you know that
must be a big advantage
it's like a score in sports yeah
football basketball yeah
i quite like this way i grew up this way
but i one thing that does trigger me is
when youngsters are like oh i think this
looks like a 0.4 position which means
nothing
yeah i mean so many people are addicted
to to these percentages now it just
makes me feel sick like you know you
analyze with um you can be someone who's
who's just started out in chess even you
know they're playing the first couple of
tournaments they say you know i don't
like your suggestion it's dropped by 0.2
my in my computer and it's like oh come
on you've got to look at the position
so you can get very obsessed by the the
computer's assessment and you can be
looking at that more than the actual
position when you're trying to trying to
learn so it's it's really important to
sometimes turn the computer off i think
you know just uh don't don't have it
working for you because you're not
learning anything by just staring at
that point going up and down all the
time that's what i tend to do when i'm
working with computers now i'm not a big
computer fan so to speak
but when i do use them i'm always like
choosing the move that comes to me
naturally and i look at the computer's
evaluation and sometimes you know it
doesn't drop that much i'm like okay
that is the move i'm going to play
because it was my instincts
yeah i think all you need actually to
evaluate a position is
you know would i prefer to be white or
would i prefer to be black yeah you
prefer white then probably white has an
advantage or at least in practical terms
it's easier to play it doesn't matter
the objectivity if it's an actual game
between two humans
sometimes it might the computer might
say plus one for black but actually
black needs to find 10 or 20 only moves
in a row and then he has an advantage
everything else and he'll lose on the
spot and in that type of situation you'd
rather be white even if the computer
disagrees
so yeah it's just whose position do you
prefer whose position you're more
attracted to and why that's the only
thing you really need to
what would
these games look like for example in the
top tournaments if the players would
have the bar on the screen would games
finish sooner would we have less
blunders perhaps
uh it feels just the evaluation bar
that's interesting because the blunters
i guess would still occur yeah but then
maybe they would be punished
really ruthlessly um because when we see
the bar swing we know there's been a big
mistake and sometimes uh we've seen
situations where someone blunders but
the other play the other player trusts
them or
the player doesn't call their bluff yeah
or the other player just isn't aware and
uh the game just goes back to zero and
it continues again
it was an argument wasn't there actually
to
bring in into online chess i think
someone was mentioning that you could
look at the evaluation like at two
points in the game uh people do it
anyway so
why not allow it and then you can like
you say you could you could really
improve the quality of your play if you
suddenly it's like someone shaking you
and saying you've got a force win here
right so that's basically what you're
getting with the evaluation if it
changes a lot then alarm bells are
ringing so you know to look for the win
when you might not might not have done
otherwise so yeah but it can also go the
other way because sometimes we've seen
the evaluation bar just go massively up
but not because of a sacrifice actually
because of positional maneuver now it's
not there's a little bit few and far
between that this happens
but
you know we've been like what's wrong
why is the computer liking it so much
and you can probably see people just
kind of implode just completely
self-destruct looking for those forcing
continuations when it's not there so
can be a double-edged sword is what i'm
saying yeah
the top players though they're so strong
they don't want to know the moves they
don't want to know the evaluation they
just want to kind of feel the position
they're there for the ride yeah and
meanwhile the queens have been exchanged
in this game
so we won't see any checkmates any
direct attacks but liam does have full
control still that lead in development i
love white's rook in the center staring
down at the black king i love this
knight in the middle of the board
it looks like a risk-free advantage and
that's all that liam needs
this game might not be over uh too
quickly though so duda just needs to
survive and keep the tension and hope
that liam eventually cracks
or that liam maybe tries too hastily to
force a draw
you know i just love this type of
position for white
i i agree i certainly do and
whilst the players are considering what
moves to play
well we are running a selfie competition
where we're asking you well to show us
where how you're watching the tour who
you're watching with
and uh marlene sutmuller says that
they're watching from the netherlands oh
thanks kathy and marlene enjoying jazz
oh look at the dog
and eras for the dog or a cat is it i
thought it was a dog no it's a cat it's
a cat it's a cat sorry my eyes
and uh it looks like a tiger
it's a very cool cat yeah whereas kevin
says that getting inspired by the super
gm symphony like plays while working on
my music nice studio let's go magnus
i've got magnus fan cheering from turkey
and remember if you want to enter our
selfie competition to have a chance at
winning the air things view wave plus
then remember to tweet us using the
hashtag chess champs with your picture
and it's best if you do it in landscape
mode
we want to see your selfies some very
cool ones they're composing some music
as well and we do see liam with
headphones probably listening to music
because they are allowed to do that in
this arena i think i've heard rumors
liam likes to listen to some classical
music yes yeah
well that's what he listened to in the
oslo esports club you know he's in miami
now
he might be inspired by
you know rap music i do i feel that's
miami style rap music maybe yeah
well
it's getting close for liam winning this
match and gaining his first points in
the tournament he will get three points
if he only gets a draw in this game the
bar is slightly over to his side the
other matches as well is going on the
bar is slightly to the middle between
the one aronian and magnus crossing
levon has to win either this game or the
next one to take it to tie breaks
because magnus carlsen is in the lead he
won the first game today the bar is
maybe going slightly towards live on
aronian side with the white pieces in
game three but still early days and
hans niemann pragnanda they are tied
winning
one game each this is uh game
three and i guess the bar is slightly
over to prague's side in this game we
will keep a close eye on that as well
aneesh giri and ali reza ferrugia i
think the bar is slightly over duality
rises aside
in that game some exciting matches going
on
he could be about to decide the match
against young christoph duda
yeah both players have been investing
quite a lot of time actually and i'm
slightly surprised because there are
some
relatively straightforward decisions i
was thinking just to improve the two
white rooks okay he's lifting one rook
up the board simon you're like this a
swinger
the rook swinging maybe towards the
black king
despite the queens being off maybe some
hints of an attack
and okay the black knight
just
finds itself on a decent square it can
get kicked away however by a pawn later
on
now we're seeing some hints on the
computer yeah um what is liam going to
do is he i don't see his mouse is he
going to click on his rook in the far
left corner the part of the screen we
can't see maybe swing that white rook in
the corner across
double up the two rooks together that
would be very sensible uh in this
position seems like blacks
should be quite happy here i mean i say
happy
considering he could have got blown off
the board 10 moves away he's getting his
king to to a safe square
his king is going to be safe he's got
kind of a
he's got a good knight you know which is
quite hard to kick away because it might
jump in
it's not as bad as it was i think it
might
be sort of playable at least now you
know four or four
so better it's got better yeah i think
it's gone a lot better and i'm not sure
about liam's last move i mean it looked
very tempting you know the bishop is
threatening to plonk itself on the f6
square but the black king is going to
cover that square
and
you know the black rook the bishop
they're coordinating very nicely
so the bishop wants to sneak in ivanka
the king
could move covering that square
threatening a nasty fork uh this pawn if
it pushes will hit the knight and hit
the bishop i guess liam's idea is to
drop the knight back uh threatening this
nasty check and a skewer
okay we'll see this happen most likely
he has dropped his knight back but now i
guess this is an easy way to stop it and
that's what duda does he chooses to drop
his bishop and
okay now the bishops have left the board
it looks bit balanced to me but the fact
that black was cramped and is now
trading off pieces that definitely is a
positive white it feels like liam is
just trying to force the exchanges
trying to force the nature of the of the
game and
to me that's a warning sign i've been
there many times myself trying to force
a draw against high-rated players or
forced to draw in a situation where that
result is good but
it never works like that you always give
your opponent chances if you take
some optimal decisions yeah and suddenly
the black bishop can kind of find itself
on a good diagonal for example
i mean yeah if you can get the bishop
there and start moving i quite like
black's pawn structure in the long run
um you know in the open h file i mean it
kind of uh
seems seems you know seems all right
actually yeah if you can get an issue
about david i mean black black could
suddenly be better couldn't he
definitely i mean no doubt that that's
okay it's just slightly peculiar yeah a
bit of an odd one i was going to say
another reason black might be better
long term is because it's one corner
island uh there's two pawn islands in
total all these pawns connect white
however has three white does have uh an
isolated pawn on the side as well as two
kind of hanging pawns uh but it's a bit
odd what dude is doing he pushed his
pawn forward i'm not sure that improves
his position too much and now
gaining space does he really want to
activate his rook this way it's very
slow though okay white meanwhile has
created a direct threat capturing a pawn
with a check
defended by the white knight
how to defend against this do you block
with your own knight do you push this
pawn i don't really want to push this
pawn because it's weakening suddenly a
big target on this square
and uh if you don't want to push the
least committal move is to bring the
rook across
that's
then the rook isn't on the open file
that you mentioned simon
so interesting decision this just feels
too slow to me why not improve your
bishop
okay black now jumping out with a knight
it's a bit extravagant
pushing the a pawn it seems when you
should be concentrating on getting your
pieces into the game
this is relying on yeah i mean this this
actually is probably a good way to
defend everything isn't it
i say it's relying on tactics but it's
not done so if white pushes a pawn to
kick away the black knight the black
knight can just retreat
and defend
uh the key f7 square also eyeing up the
white bishop so the knight will be quite
well placed at first i thought white
could maybe simplify things and force a
draw by capturing a pawn
and uh here pushing a pawn forward
because there's a pin along this line
but suddenly the black rook could come
down and pin the white pawn and i don't
think this will end very well for white
you can't regain the night that you
sacrificed at least not just yet
so instead liam drops his bishop back
and yeah it does feel like he's trying
to force things and it's not quite
working so far
surely now it's time to activate one of
these two pieces
yeah and he's trying to maybe just
exchange off that night make more
exchanges as you say but
it's uh it's
still okay for him still probably a draw
is likely but it's it's a game of chess
now yeah yeah definitely still enough
pieces for duda to kind of
whip up some kind of imbalance and
cause some uh
cause some concern for liam later
i mean i i quite like what dude is doing
you know he's taking a very maximalist
approach you know he's
grabbing space
and saying to liam he believes he has
faith that the position on the right
will hold
and
it's remarkable that we are 27 moves in
and the light square bishop has not left
its starting square can stay there the
whole
game giant yeah
do you think it will break out by move
or make not break out move
why move 30. um
but what move we're 27. no chance
no
give it move 40 maybe
well two games have finished in this
round three it's a draw between hans
niman and pragnanda still tied after
three games it could all be decided in
game four if we have a winner in that
game if that one two is a draw well then
those two will fight it out in blitz tie
breaks and so will anish geary and ali
reservoir three draws in their match so
far if we have a winner between them in
game four that will be the winner of the
match and if it's a draw then blitz tie
breaks it's looking very likely that we
will see some dramatic blitz tie breaks
today as well
let's hope for that
and this one it's very unlikely
very unlikely but dude is keeping his
small his kind of slim chances alive
uh now he just brings this rook across
defending the slightly tender f7 pawn
a bit passive gotta say i'm expecting
harry the h pawn white's each pawn to
step forward two squares now you might
as well okay there we go we see it on
liam's screen i think he's just about
played it there we go white's h1 did
step forward you might as well push
pawns on the side where you're stronger
and that's where white has potentially a
past h-pawn black's knight stepping back
okay bit of a threat
yeah but uh that's about it you know
he's just threatening to move the
knights centralize itself attack the
road
what move is it it is move thirty
should have had a bet there simon yeah
close though yeah so the light squared
bishop does have a nice square now on b7
to attack white's rook on the long
diagonal
mm-hmm it just feels like it's turning i
know the evaluation bar is still not too
concerned but
it does feel like
dude is at least creating something
well i like the bar but i trust you more
david
i've learned that
i don't know i mean it's still in the
balance i think objectively it's equal
just in terms of human psychology
now all three results definitely
possible the tension is building
and normally that favors the side who
has something
kind of to well who can take risk who
can uh kind of has nothing else to lose
like duda if you have something to cling
to like liam then you do take these
negative decisions like he's been doing
in this game swapping queens swapping
bishops
okay now the bishop did move move 31
and white's rook is going to jump out
the way yeah i was going to say it's
super important actually to maintain
those light squared bishops because you
know if you do initiate a trade then
this is simply going to favor black
suddenly black's works are going to be
way more active there's going to be a
lot more potential with his pawn
structure because it's a like more
flexible
and
this is not in white's interest what
needs to keep the rooks on and perhaps
generate some attacking possibilities on
the right
so we're expecting white rook to move
somewhere on the third rank
and uh okay it's going to be a bit of a
time scramble as well both sides now
down under four minutes
yeah who would you pick i'm still
struggling i think i would pick black if
anyone just the momentum of the game
um i mean having survived that kind of
nightmare opening where he was actually
lost after what 10 moves
to i mean this is a dream position to
reach
yeah i agree i mind just just
psychologically um it's going to be
tough
for white now to sort of
well i mean you know to get into the
right frame mood i think so and uh jan's
got nothing to lose in this game so i
think there's a great chance it'll be a
fourth fourth game coming up actually
time the boat yeah like you said they're
both getting low nothing
that concerning at the moment yeah i
could just see scenarios where somehow
white pawns on the left side of the
board they come under fire from black's
knight or or black's rook can attack
actually white pawns on the right side
as well
i mean it's still
a lot to play for
i also think that uh liam will as the
clock starts ticking down make a
committal decision and duda you know
he's been in this situation before i can
remember one final where he played
against magnus
he was two nil down magnus just needed a
draw
and uh
dudeo was fine yeah judah struck back
and it was a hopeless position out of
the opening
and
the one thing i will say about duda is
that he is the opposite of a morning
person he likes to wake up in the
afternoon and they do start the games at
12 o'clock he's had success on the tour
when we start at uh 6 p.m european time
he's kind of peaking he's reaching uh
kind of his freshest
in the afternoon evening but
i remember tournaments where he's waking
up to 3 p.m in the afternoon and
this is not ideal for him body clock is
such an important thing especially in
speed chess
and despite winning
on the first day
for me he's just not quite at his
sharpest normally i'm expecting i'm kind
of used to seeing duda just
super aggressive just throwing pieces at
the opponent taking massive risks
and uh imbalancing things here it just
feels yeah
i mean he feels like he's a bit slow
he's now just spent nearly two minutes
on this last move
not sure whether it's a great one it's a
provocative move attacking white's pawn
in the corner asking white to step some
pawns forward
but yeah it just feels like he's a bit
tentative we saw that in the blitz
yesterday against levon aronian he was
slow
at least what we're uh compared to
normal
but i do remember also esports cup he
had a very slow start to the tournament
and he won the whole thing he was like a
submarine right yeah
from nowhere suddenly oh look at that
dude is in fourth place or third place
oh yeah can you relate to him with uh
the sleeping though david the you need
to wake up late in the day and i would
hate playing at 12 o'clock
didn't you do that in the olympian was
it 12 it was 3 p.m oh it was three okay
you're fine i never once woke up before
11 30.
and uh
okay
is
what is this okay i thought this was a
bit of a blunder but no maybe the black
rook
is safe enough it looks like an odd
choice of square simon um this rook in
the eye line of white's light squared
bishop
but so yeah say for now
i mean i'd like to get rid of that
bishop as well so i guess the natural
move is to bring the knight back into
the center
um
look at the forcing moves first so that
that move would attack the rook and aim
to exchange the bishop often
but you know i i think the way dude is
playing this dude is
going for white's a pawn the pawn on the
side of the board and if black can ever
capture that pawn then he's gonna he's
gonna have he's gonna have a runner yeah
he's gonna have a runner coming down the
board
harry the a pawn and i know i know
you're gonna say alice but i'm still
saying harry
he's running so we're seeing it simon uh
white's version of alice is about to
drop yeah but what can happen here i
guess you can capture this bishop in the
center of the board the black knight has
to take back due to a pin on this line
the black knight has to capture
i don't know do we really see a rook
takes pawn move and allow black his
choice of pawns over here it feels like
maybe we can go like bishop c4 or
something if we want the draw maybe this
is uh a okay particular way to do it so
he's gone for
another option david okay dropping his
bishop back there is a trap i guess if
rook takes this pawn then the white
knight will jump out the way checking
the black king gaining time and next
move the white rook has a discovered
attack will win the black rook
and he's kind of hoping for the same if
the rook captures the other pawn
that's done actually and i'm guessing
that white will now attack the bishop
and once the bishop steps away then the
knight will jump into the f5 square and
there will be rook takes rook
but i have to say yes
the operation was a success but it might
ultimately be a failure because that's a
lot of pawns
that have uh come
with
that uh maneuver it's getting messy as
well very messy so he actually drops his
bishop back to a different square now
after the night check i guess his idea
is knight takes night the white rook
captures the black rook and now knight
takes pawn and you're right simon it's a
lot of pawns hitting this bishop now i'm
threatening a nasty knight check
on the f3 square
this one looks very good for black
suddenly yeah does white have something
better in the current position other
than this knight check because
if he doesn't
i mean maybe you could flick in this one
first and then do the night check but
again a lot of pawns
suddenly liam is the one fighting for
his life both sides around two minutes
yeah black is a pawn up he has something
to cling to
and you're right david and simon because
the best move for white is actually to
flick in that pawn move
according to the computer and there's a
second pawn move actually the white can
play which it suggests which is also
quite a unique is actually to pick up
harry and move it up one square
and uh that one's a bit unusual we won't
see that one we definitely won't and
then why it's a third option is actually
to play the check but there black would
be better yeah so i mean the reason i'm
so
uh well skeptical about this move is it
seems to be playing
very slowly not creating any immediate
threat but maybe some ideas against the
black king but yeah this one forcing
yeah this one forcing things in the
center i guess you get that by process
of elimination you see that the night
check wasn't so attractive as we showed
and now maybe the night check is more
effective because there are some ideas
of uh this knight being attacked so
after knight takes night also after the
black knight jumps in
at least now this bishop is blocked and
we're going to see this happen uh we're
going to see it on the board i'm not
sure where the knight is going you could
make an argument for capturing this pawn
you could jump in the center which way
uh i think black's got everything you
want he wants so all of a sudden from
the opening which is
horrible he's got uh if you if you need
to win the game the first thing to do is
unbalance the situation get some kind of
material um situation which is not
symmetrical and that's what dude has got
he's got uh he's got a very unbalanced
situation now and uh this means the
winning chances have increased greatly
massively absolutely you're right simon
uh for example if you take this pawn
even if we see i mean a bunch of
exchanges here actually we can't do this
can we because now there's a night check
at the end i mean they're so tricky now
this knight is jumping all over the
place but i was going to say in this
position if we do a quick count black
does have at least for now three pawns
and a knight for a rook so black is
actually up on material
i i really hate what's happened for liam
here he's lost
completely lost control and he has to be
accurate now to fight for his life yeah
maybe he has to give a check try and uh
maybe exchange a set of rooks if he can
achieve this then maybe now he can
contemplate uh capturing this pawn or
maybe capturing this one first i'm not
sure which way but he needs to hoover
the pieces off the board and make that
draw because it's not going to last for
long
things are turning in black's favor
yeah definitely and those two pawns that
are there by themselves on the right
side to the left side of the board and
then they have the potential to be very
scary um he doesn't actually give the
rook check he decides to keep both sets
of brook on the board and instead
attacks the bishop
the bishop drops back and now i guess
his idea is to give the rook check he
will trade off a set of rooks
and we see this happen and at the very
end white's idea
again i guess you take this pawn uh but
you could make oh actually i'm not sure
about this one because suddenly the
black pawns step forward
maybe the idea is to take this pawn uh
instead and
you're just hoping that everything comes
off the board but i would choose black
just so many pawns black can keep
bishops on the board even by taking here
both sides of the board black will have
an advantage
oh
and he takes the risk and
he does take the other pawn and suddenly
these two are rolling
he's lost control yeah it just depends i
mean if that blackball goes one square
further forwards
it's it's got to be black he's going to
be winning this now
um i mean
already some calculations there yeah i
mean all i'm seeing is that the black
king will suddenly start mobilizing
itself
and then it will just park itself on the
d6 square and
all it takes is for black to now use and
utilize the knight and then get on with
the goal of pushing those pawns
and uh well dude that just does it yeah
one-sided traffic white's pawn is easily
blockaded where do you even put the rook
he puts on this square and as ivanka
mentions night check get that knight off
the rim off the side of the board
uh wow you can't even go to the square
there's all sorts of night forks that
i'm falling into here um liam's gotta
hope he doesn't fall into them i guess
you go this direction but at the very
least the black knight ends up on a nice
central square
i'm not sure you even go this way maybe
you can go this way too after some weak
after some weaknesses
it's all about dudeo right now i think
we will see a game for in this match
yeah definitely
turn around yep looks that way i mean um
i think definitely
black's gonna win this one now to two
connected past pawns and just the tide
of this game since the opening has just
gone in dude his way he's played so well
to come back though shows his fighting
spirit and uh you know why why he's
playing this tournament i mean it's that
extra percentage a lot of these players
have isn't it you know they they're
there's other players who are maybe
similar to them but they're not as good
because they just sort of maybe give up
a little bit too early um but in
hopeless situations i i would have
resigned probably uh these guys just
continue you know they fight on and
it looks like uh we get that fourth game
so yeah i mean definitely looks like the
opening gamble pain paid off
well i'm not sure about that
it was it was still pretty bad wasn't it
you know i mean
you know it was a really bad opening
wasn't it but impressive fighting spirit
by duda and is it also that
sort of uh
liam just playing too much on that draw
that he needed
and ending up in this bad situation yeah
definitely you know he had a great
position out of the opening
and uh he perhaps played a little bit
too safely at points and then he just
tried to force the draw and as you can
see it's not happening because there are
two players playing chess unfortunately
and uh black's past pawns they are going
to start running
yeah
i mean it's difficult to even see a
saving
grace here for him he just has to hope
that somehow all the pawns on the right
side just disappear get traded off and
then he can give up maybe a bishop for
those two scary uh past pawns on the
other flank
it takes a lot of work though um
yeah i mean he really does need a
miracle despite what the evaluation bar
says
it is very very scary okay he's trying
to force the issue here he's given up
one pawn
okay he's going after those two runners
maybe this is clever he's extremely
resourceful isn't he um you know liam
yeah you see time and time again where
he gets these horrible positions but
now maybe he's gonna sort of start
fighting like like uh duder yeah 20
seconds for duda the clock is ticking
yeah yeah
you can't actually defend that pawn
that's uh under fire on b5
yeah you're right simon this is an
incredible resource where did he find
this one i mean just tricking the black
knight away just for one second and then
winning the black b5 pawn if one of
those two black pawns falls the other
one will as well looks like a draw now
yeah
can i say that it keeps changing
i just if i say every single result
i'll probably probably get it right
somehow
that's my plan you've got one and three
right
right i've covered my back exactly
five seconds okay so maybe a draw but
you take black
yeah yeah i mean it's a technical draw
if you get rid of the a pawn isn't it
because the king is in front of those
pawns and i think you just get the rook
behind and that's supposed to be a draw
as far as i remember um
but
it's still not easy
i've lost it
yeah okay all right it's not easy then
definitely not i better not say it's
easy how easy no no it's definitely a no
definitely it's tricky yeah because
those two pawns can be uh very dangerous
yeah and it looks unlikely that black
will be able to keep that a pawn maybe
you can keep it for a while with some
tricky checks with some tricky tactics
but
um that a pawn is just all alone and
even if the black knight goes across the
defend black will be completely tied
down so
this is reverses this is a technical
draw isn't it nowadays i don't care i
mean it is but
you know um but we've talked talking
about computer evaluations it says 0.0
we know it's a draw with best play but
black is the only one who can win so
white is the one who has to prove that
it's 0.0 yeah you still need a lot of
hard work so change the check
is he trying to hold on to that pawn
maybe
i was wondering where the white king
should go should it step up and try to
munch on those pawns on the right
and uh that is the approach that liam's
gone for
i i was tempted to do that
makes a lot of sense if you can win both
of black's pawns on the right side then
you can even give up your rook for the
remaining pawn on the other flank and
knight is not enough to checkmate alone
uh so yeah why not start moving towards
those pawns you could move towards the
night now as well maybe this is the
simplest
amazing amazing little i'm not really
sure what happened there liam just
finding that that great little one move
wasn't it that one moment which saved
the game where he found this very clever
idea
uh which which obviously the computer
had seen but so hard to find him in the
game
today
look at liam you know accurate as ever
you know he retreats the king to attack
the knight
uh with the same idea of just pursuing
that knight improving the king's
position and now
it looks like it's totally drawn
sure
and he's not even allowing any checks
for the knight so he's really
controlling everything here yeah he
didn't even want to take that black uh a
pawn to the pole now there is a troll
now
yeah it would be a night fork if the
black if the white rook takes that black
pawn black's knight jumps to the c5
square with a fork so try and keep the
white king and rook as far away as
possible from each other that's the
um that's the idea here
and just keep checking if in doubt
the black king doesn't really have
too safe a square
wait no it doesn't mean no safe square
at all definitely not and if it steps
back then this doesn't invite the king
to come forward
yeah yeah the white king would love to
step forward and uh probably will do so
right now
yeah
looks like it secures the draw unless
we're missing something
uh missing something here
duder yeah
trying for some chances but looking away
now because he knows that the uh the win
has definitely gone
white is just going to pick up all the
black pawns
that's kind of a cruel game for him
because if you're going to lose like
this you just lose out the opening it's
not so bad but you lose you get your
hope up again you're like yeah
and then you lose again and it's like
you know it's kind of uh it's tough
right yeah we've all been there right
many times yeah
i mean
chess is brutal justice brutal game but
and i always try to explain like people
who don't
play competitions sometimes they they
don't realize the emotions that you you
can go through and they say you know
it's only a game or something but it's
it's literally
one of the worst feelings in the world
isn't it to lose
lose a bad game of chess sometimes you
know very hard to compare it to anything
else not just the computer evaluations
it's the flow of the game it's like ups
and downs and having to adapt to new
scenarios
yeah i think liam's trying to play for a
win here to be honest just the way he's
going yeah he could i don't know why he
didn't take that a pawn i mean
it was this is a bit bit surprising but
this way i think you just uh
nail it as well you can capture the pawn
and there's just no way the black king
can assist in the quest to promote those
two remaining pawns
and
it almost feels like you can go for more
really
happy just play it safe now get rid of
both
you don't want to start running even
further yeah
this is just in time isn't it yeah so
just uh
quite close you can see on liam's face
as well he's a bit disappointed he wants
to win this game yeah but he's resigned
himself to the fact okay i'll take the
draw i'll win the match take the money
and the draw yeah i'll say and i think
dude is going to try one last trick
which
won't work
who do we who do we think is partying
the hardest in miami then
now of all the players maybe liam after
this game yeah
i can't see liam being a big party here
no offense to liam but i think he's
quite serious about his chess
um i can see your
am every morning you know
well it's a party today for liam le two
wins and a draw in this game it's over
after three games he takes all three